no you [ __ ] no use funny it's the
ongoing joke about welcome back to
genius brain podcast with I'm your host
Bo's Bo's Eaton and I'm bringing back my
special guest David so David glad to
have you back it's crazy because I feel
like you're here more often than I am
yeah it's crazy because I am literally
here when you're not all the [ __ ]
time thanks for coming on so we're gonna
do an advice column I want to say that
it's coming from your page because this
is my show you know it'd be so [ __ ] up
like this starts as a joke and then all
the comments are like you know what both
would be a good house I would [ __ ]
die I will [ __ ] die and if you ever
write a comment like that below this I
will find you and I will but [ __ ] your
teddy bear like a whole network it's
like as you're talking this poster just
turns into your face slowly it's like
the buzz show but it's just a photo of
me like I'm like what is going on the
colors start changing cast and crew gets
in here the right choice or the chain if
they're vacuuming the floor I'm not even
allowed to be on the mic sir get off the
set can you close the door get the [ __ ]
out yes I guess I will go [ __ ] what is
happening welcome back to the people are
waiting for you to have a podcast though
because you there's also hey [ __ ] yeah
hey beachy hey [ __ ] green people's in
also but I'm just gonna put it out there
cuz I like promoting people stuff thank
you
wait this [ __ ] about to pop off I truly
hope so I truly hope so that's the Midas
touch whatever you touched me really
well it's almost time for the leap of
faith man you know almost is I mean I've
been in my job for I've been broke cuz I
told you I told you the job I got your
qualified one day because like you know
I work in like nine oh two one oh and so
I was like walking around all these
white people around load a hose right
around the corner I'm like with my
Starbucks and I'm like wow it's so weird
it really is about what you who or what
you grow up around with because when I'm
in a group full of white people I feel
really uncomfortable I feel like I don't
belong oh oh oh I will say I went on a
little vacation to Malibu because I
thought I was like there yeah and I felt
very out of place it's like we're not
like there yet
oh you were you were doing yourself a
self ocation right oh dude yeah I got I
got my own place like near the water
Thanks was riding horses yeah I'm gonna
horseback ride I took myself out to Nobu
like I was and I just bought a car that
weekend I was not playing tell me about
that car situation cuz you were going
off on Twitter she's going the [ __ ] off
okay David this is what I did so I I've
been in LA for three years I didn't I
never had a car what the jobs I worked
before I had a stipend for
transportation so it just didn't make
sense for me to get a car well the new
job I have no stipend so I was like damn
I guess I should so there was one week I
had a lot of [ __ ] to do I'm normally
over everywhere and so I rented a car
cuz it was cheaper and I loved it I
loved driving around so much that the
day I had to turn in the rental I
started looking for a new car I yeah
like that I was like damn what have I
been doing I need a car and I don't I
personally I'm not out here trying to
get a Lexus right now I don't need to
flex I don't need to I know I know how
I'm doing I don't need to show the whole
world I just want something cheap
efficient that is gonna get me from A to
B and looks alright so I obviously I'm
gonna get a Civic so I go to the I go to
the dealership I'll walk in they try to
tell me um because if your credit it's
gonna be like 365 a month and I was like
no it's not gonna be 365 a month because
it's a [ __ ] Civic and it's the end of
the year and I just won a 20-19 help me
help you get this off the lot yeah it
didn't work out I walked out the calling
me the next day I so what I did was this
is like my best tip for like doing
anything at all like with a car with
getting a car I went on one of those
kind of generic lease websites like not
a specific Honda dealership just a
generic one and I basically put out a
beacon to every Honda dealership that
said I'm looking for a 2019 Civic and
immediately every dealership in LA
started calling they're like we did get
rid of this [ __ ] yeah they wanted to get
rid of it I'd also buy in November so
they all start calling me and what
them was hey I'm at work right now can
you write that down for me in an email
I'll come pick up the car tomorrow but
here's what I'm looking for and I gave
them my price and so every single
dealership emailed me their offer so
then I started sending the offers to
different dealerships and making them
come down and down and down and down
from where they came from 365 for a
[ __ ] Honda Civic I got down to 169
with tax included yeah I mean that's
that is where I met 169 for a [ __ ]
Honda Civic with taxes included and also
when I got it down to that price I had
it between two dealerships and then two
Honda dealerships they gave me 169 with
taxes included despite they try to say
microns but Mitch my card is not bad at
7:10 [ __ ] you no that's [ __ ] great
what are they talking about yeah they
tried to save in my experience score was
lower and then I was like well I want a
car right now and I'm not waiting for my
experience score to catch up with the
others so either you give me the car I'm
going to go somewhere else yeah and like
I was like that's that that's that's
what the plan is
so when I got down to these two
dealerships they were gonna give me 169
a month taxes included there was one
that told me okay so your down payment
though it's gonna be 2,000 plus drive up
fees family the drive off fees were
eight hundred to a thousand dollars yes
yeah so I came back and I said no I took
out this amount from my bank account I
was very firm with it I had walked out
of the dealership two times at this
point I said I took exactly $2,100 out
of my bank account it takes five days
for that to transfer and I want the car
now so you either take this or I'm gonna
go to this dealership and get the car
they're like sorry we can't do that and
I was like okay I'm going to the other
dealership and while I was at the other
dealership they called me and they were
like okay we'll give it to you just just
come down right now and I was like all
right so I went down there and I [ __ ]
got it I walked out three times I had
all these dealerships and I need you to
get my car okay I thought my [ __ ] was
good it's way better I will I will [ __ ]
yes so I got it I got a 20-19 brand new
Civic she's beautiful I love her taxes
included 169 I feel like if there's a
cuz if ur at the back of your head and
if I took it down you're eighty year old
Asian man
Kuang them young
and also that's the other thing David I
I was dealing with the same guy each
time I went to the dealership because
when I bought it for her I went back to
third I can't remember I bought it on
the third time on the fourth time but
what I also learned was they thought
because I'm a woman oh they was trying
to get one on you they were trying to
get one on me but what happened was
because I'm a woman I was complaining I
wasn't arguing with this man I was
complaining I complained to everyone I
haven't told this [ __ ] and cuz I
know the salesman has to talk to the the
show this floor manager or something
it's really not his call and I was like
okay well tell the floor manager to call
me so I complained him too I was on the
phone I was like look it's a [ __ ]
Honda Civic like let's be real and then
I was like the sticker price you're not
even marking this down I walked on ready
and I was speaking their language I was
doing all this [ __ ] he was like all
right okay okay ladies they don't want
to hear you complain they do not want to
hear you complain and for a car salesman
time is money
once you take up five or six hours of
their time they're losing other sales
and they have to keep dealing with you
until you buy it
that's pretty [ __ ] good I don't have
the patience for that [ __ ] your name is
dong fan from now about - do you know
what I was about to do [ __ ] take that
when I did a test-drive of it because
they'll let you drive it around for a
while sometimes they'll let you drive it
if they trust you with all your [ __ ]
they'll let you drive it for the day
I should have taken that car and driven
it down to another dealership and been
like you know I think I'm about to buy
this car do you all have you crazy for
that much that's crazy I got dirt cheap
because I wasn't settling for any less I
didn't I didn't really want a car why
why would I pay to drive my car I hunt I
have a Honda which I love by the way but
that's just becoming problematic Honda
Element that shit's [ __ ] I should I
probably spent I spent more money fixing
it than I did buying it just because I
love it and I'm also just a very
stubborn human being and I don't like
people being right so they were like you
know that she's gonna break down like
ice ain't gonna break down if I put
seven thousand dollars to fix it up you
could at least a brand new car for that
bro don't don't tell me [ __ ] oh yeah I
cannot wait until it's time to get my
next car because your boys gonna be way
richer and I'm gonna be a lot more savvy
with
this [ __ ] I'm like I want my next car I
would really want to get a Corvette
Stingray you trying to get a Corvette in
LA you trying to scrape up everything my
god that's just like an inch away from
the floor any of the Beverly Hills
Beverly Hills is the worst place to have
a [ __ ] corner I want it so bad that's
the dream car but I think I'm gonna go
out of state to get it I love a good
deal David I love Asian to the [ __ ]
there's like a master base to [ __ ]
coupons of [ __ ] David my god look at
this right at this turkey used to be a
dollar pound now that's crazy let me
tell you about my current cups that I
got then I'm paying eight cents per cup
of coffee oh there are some people who
are like convenience [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a deal [ __ ] you would love that
you know it's true though like buying
stuff at the price that is not supposed
to be you're a [ __ ] freak did good I
feel like when you when you [ __ ] to you
like you better you better talk about
like some honey deals right now when
honey came out and they started putting
off this little online coupons through
the Ralphs app a through your grocery
app you can put digital coupons on your
like Ralph's card so that when you go to
scan the card the coupons are already
loaded to the card so you don't look
corny with a bunch of coupons but you
save all that money David oh really yes
target does it to you load the coupon
onto your card that everybody scans oh
sure oh yeah David that's how I got
those curated cups for eight cents each
I didn't know that [ __ ] and why are you
talking all sexual [ __ ] right now is
what turns me on a good [ __ ] D am I
about on tinder would just be in all
capital letters love a good deal you and
Steve could talk about cuz Steve is a
[ __ ] cheap [ __ ] oh dude I
love it I love love love it like oh dude
I'll haggle for anything I'm not even
looking for an apartment right now and I
went to look at this apartment cuz
sometimes this is so wack I feel like
I've put all my secrets out on David
show in order to motivate myself
sometimes I'll go look at her apartments
or house because I live in a
rent-controlled apartment I live in a
huge one-bedroom that I got for dirt
cheap for how much I got oh I can't tell
you it's a good deal it's a real good
deal and my rent only goes up by like
$60 a year yeah it's rent-controlled
okay so it's a yam I'm so impatient good
I don't got that [ __ ] dude I I will wait
I'll wait for it I will and I won't I'll
try not to buy from corporations I'll
buy from like a single owner something
like that but yeah so I went to look at
this apartment the other day that was
pretty close to mine it was like a
really pretty one bedroom and I told and
she told me that the price for it was
2700 and I was like damn I was like wow
I was like it's 2700 even with all the
construction outside and she was like
well I mean yeah but all these amenities
in bed VII and I was like but that's
subway construction that's gonna be
there for five years and you're charging
2700 for this where the view is the
construction and she was like well I
mean we can definitely discuss that
depending on the move-in date you know
that could be reasonable yeah I'll
handle an apartment you weren't even
gonna move okay that's [ __ ] right
David
this girl after she after she broke her
to this deal she went to the car she
masturbated for an hour
she mugging finger-banged herself in the
car she's like yeah you get that [ __ ]
from me for 22 man I'm like I'm not okay
at haggling but it's just like more
about the convenience at a time but
that's definitely a hobby of yours
though like you definitely love that
[ __ ] well because I work in marketing I
do I do
hundreds of thousands of dollars of ad
buys every month and and so I deal
directly with the salespeople each day
but because I work for like a billion
dollar company I have unlimited budgets
yeah in in my work life so I'm not
afraid to walk away from the salesman
sometimes like if Washington Post wants
my money then like they need to give it
to me at my price so I've learned to not
be afraid to walk away or what to say in
these situations by playing with
my company's money I'm still doing my
job obviously but I've just learned a
lot in it and it's bled into my real
life for like I'm not afraid to walk
away from something I I think people
just be [ __ ] you save so much money I'm
over here because Bart's not like that
Bart's the convenience guy Bart Bart
just be dropping money for no [ __ ]
reason he's just like mr. bean I'm just
gonna do it gonna save some time you
know but it's like man I feel like that
the money that you saved though it's
like some real [ __ ] oh yeah absolutely
absolutely and and I and I I'm happy I'm
really happy when I [ __ ] do it you
know I gotta get on your [ __ ] level
dude we got to figure this [ __ ] out I'd
be wasting money on a lot of [ __ ] cuz
I'm looking for a new car and I there's
a car that I would look here we go
there's a car that I want to get right
now and you know I'm more of a
functional person you know people
because like I'm a 5 foot tall woman and
like I come in and like I don't budge
like I don't I had a meeting with your
people a while ago oh yeah I thrillers
always at a table with three men and we
were talking we were talking about [ __ ]
and like I didn't budge and you know
what they told me at the end they were
like yeah you don't you don't take any
[ __ ] and then the other guy was like no
she does and I was like thank you men
it's funny can like yeah I mean
especially when it comes like deals and
when you're working on the stuff like
there's like this weird fine line of
figuring out okay
what's what's the basis in which I need
these requirements that need to be met
and what can I give and take on right
yeah I think a lot of the times like
what makes you know us look bad is when
there's people out there who just walk
into a meeting and they bend over and
they open up their butthole yeah okay
[ __ ] me in the ass please you know what
but I mean it's also because a lot of
times people aren't in situations where
they can walk away and like I said I
kind of got that fortified in me from
work yeah I get to dangle $25,000 over
somebody's head and if they want my
money they need to dance
and so I've I've I've learned how to
make them dance
[Laughter]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean really
knowing like I mean I have to I have to
make people dance all the time and if I
don't like the way that they're dancing
I leave oh you made me want to work
harder like you really do like I feel
like I'm so lackadaisical about
everything that I do I don't really like
really [ __ ] go for something unless
I'm making some type of food I mean
because it but the beautiful thing is
it's coming to you so easily so I mean
yeah if you the thing is is like if
you're happy with where you are then
great but if you aren't happy you know
that you just have to put that extra
oomph in it and you could own like a
motivational speaker you even know you
by default you're making me feel like a
piece of [ __ ] and that's how I get
motivated no David you're making you
already think you're a piece of [ __ ] I
know but I need to think of it more I
don't think I'm a piece of [ __ ] enough
where I need to work harder thing like
some people when I found out to this one
I thought for my mom when I'm I was
trying to motivate my brother and people
get motivated through different ways
right and just because you get motivated
a certain way doesn't mean somebody else
will feel the same way and so I will try
to motivate my brother to do better by
calling him a [ __ ] loser so I thought
that it would because we grew up in the
same household so it's like oh if I
recognize that I'm acting like a loser
maybe I'm gonna [ __ ] sack up I'm
gonna do some [ __ ] right but I was
tearing him down the way I wanted to be
spoken to right yo man don't be a
[ __ ] a little [ __ ] ass [ __ ] wake
the [ __ ] up and do some [ __ ] what you
gonna wake up every day and just be like
this all the time and keep going it's
like I get it I love it you know and I'm
thinking you know going to sleep every
night David you did a good job and I
wake up in the morning and he's
demoralized and I talk to my mom like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with her she says
well have you been talking to him but
call him a little [ __ ] that's what I'm
supposed to do she goes no like you
don't you can't talk to him the way you
want to be spoken to she was you're the
type of person when somebody feels like
they're doubting you you want to prove
people wrong it was like your brother
has never been like that he needs he
needs to be uplifted with
to words he needs kindness and then
he'll he'll feel better than he'll do
better he goes that's how he works
because you're different you can't talk
to him like that
and for like a year straight I was
calling him a piece of [ __ ] and I
thought I was helping
but yeah you are one of those people
that like you're one of those people
were like and like you can tell yourself
okay Jeff's is very similar Jess will
like beat herself up she'll beat herself
up all day I'm stupid like bah bah but
the minute that you come in you're like
yeah you are stupid she's like what
nobody can say that but me and then she
rises to the occasion and I was like
that too you know and like you know if I
say like David you [ __ ] suck what are
you doing you could be doing so much
better you're like because it's like
nobody can say that to us to us boys
don't look like behave it's podcast
[Laughter]
actually girl yeah almost are having
different guests on I'm sorry having
schedules and [ __ ] I'm just more like
you tried to talk wear it out we were
like gonna do this I was like oh I'm I
hadn't being like over to your shoot
days and you're like I know what you
free we could make it happen a very
[ __ ] loose with my [ __ ] did I feel
like a oh let's go to the topic I forgot
oh hold on let's see
so today interesting so we usually do
this with Joe but we got bows you're the
first Subban to ever do an advice column
or we call it the genius suggestions
because we don't call it advice because
of legal reasons and we might get [ __ ]
suggestions and you take it or leave it
you jackasses usually like is it jizz
you and Joe being like [ __ ] you we try
to keep it well-rounded okay you know to
the best of my ability but not everybody
knows who I am like if I think you're
doing something dumb I'll say it because
I'm trying to basically talk to my
future self or my former self actually
so this is from patreon so if you guys
assigned to the patreon you guys get to
suggest everything on genius brain and
this is from Logan
listen I'm gonna listen now Logan this
is what Logan wrote shoutouts to Logan
okay so this is my situation I am 21
still living with my parents trying to
save up money to move in the next year
or a year and a half they've been
married for 20 years and recently about
six months ago my dad found out my mom
was talking to another guy behind his
back oh okay oh no [ __ ] skank just
kidding ever since then my dad has been
very untruthful with mom but wanted to
work things out although it might have
hurt him to learn he wanted to work it
out
but he's I think they're very emotional
they were oh there was another snake
sense my mom feels she is being attacked
every time for not doing anything bad
but she was clearly doing something wait
but the mom was talking to somebody
right exactly so I think what he means
is that at the time he felt like she was
doing something mine is back but she
would get highly defensive and angry
because he was to suggest things but it
turns out that it was true my mom feels
she is being attacked every time for not
doing anything bad but she was clearly
doing something behind his back she even
told family members of her side that she
is being attacked by her family we have
tried telling her she doesn't open up we
can't help her every day she blames
everything on my dad even though he's
trying the best to talk to her don't get
me wrong because he is also in the wrong
in my opinion because over the years
I've never seen from either side trying
to be better for one another this has
affected me in a way where I can no
longer see them the same from when I was
seven years I wanted from when I was
seven very specific number when they
were happy yes they would bicker about
things but they would get through it so
the question is what do I do because at
this point I feel like moving out and
parting ways from my family because
it'll give me a break mentally PS this
is how I feel for the rest of my
extended family as well so the whole
situation right now is that your
emotions and how you feel about your
parents have changed because you've seen
them go through this very terrible thing
where you're seeing your your first of
all your mom cheated on your dad and you
saw a very dishonest side from your mom
and you also see a very bad side from
your father and you you want to feel the
type of love that you felt for your
parents when you were seven right off
the bat unrealistic
this look at the genius suggestions I'm
not saying I don't feel bad for you I
really do um here's here's the thing
we're just gonna start this right here
your parents are human and when you're
younger it's very very hard to see them
as human beings
yeah when your kid your dependents like
there are some parents that aren't great
but assuming that your parents were
loving nurturing your parents are
Superman and superwoman to you they can
do no wrong
they are the parent you are the child
they're this almighty all-seeing force
and you you follow them they are your
Shepherd and you believe them so it's
not crazy that once they become human
and that's no longer hidden from you
that things change yeah and you see like
your parents kryptonite like when you
first watch Superman bleed for the first
time it's like oh [ __ ] Superman can
[ __ ] bleed yeah and that's a hard
thing you're at the age of 21 too
because that's around the time I started
to realize that my parents were human as
well like they had feelings that they
hurt when I say things to them it
actually hurts them it hurts their
feelings and it makes them cry makes
them very vulnerable yeah when I was
younger I didn't get that [ __ ] at all
whatsoever because I thought like oh my
parents are always hurting me and no
matter what I say to them it doesn't is
that like I consciously thought about
that [ __ ] but it was already in my head
and it's also when you start to reach my
age where I'm like 31 32 now it's like
uh-huh
my parents are gonna die hmm like
they're not gonna be here forever
yeah and that that thought like you're
going through the first stages of it
where you're starting to realize that
there's chinks in their armors right
yeah you know it actually I went through
this exact situation and like I'm
actually gonna like I just I've never
processed it before ever so I'm gonna
process it here and try to walk through
this experience with this person but
I'll give you a back story on it first
yeah this was like actually really rough
when I was very young lives when
Facebook first came out one day I
randomly got a message from this guy out
of nowhere and he said hey hope you been
well
just went introduce myself my name is
so-and-so and I'm your Grandpa's son and
I was like I don't know this guy
and I tell my mom about it and she
just like okay don't talk to him just
like blah blah I start to look looks
exactly like my grandpa
looked at his pictures and I was like
holy [ __ ]
grandparents don't sleep in the same bed
you know they they they don't I didn't
you know just a few things started
clicking and what ended up happening was
I I what I believed that my grandpa was
Superman he is this all seeing all know
is this wonderful beautiful person that
could do no wrong and it clicks like he
had cheated on my grandma and not only
that but had a child that he was not
taken care of and this child wanted to
connect with his family and what I did
at 16 was I rejected him because I
didn't want to believe that my grandpa
had done this this person is human to me
at the time was a symbol of this this
belief that it it cracked it cracked
something in it shattered this reality
of my grandpa and I didn't want to
believe it
so and that is something that has
haunted me for a long time I've since
then connected with that guy
this was over 10 years ago but at the
time I didn't want to believe it I
wanted to keep believing this false
reality so the first thing you need to
do is accept that crack if it's
something that's completely shattered
you need to accept that
um damn I feel bad I feel really bad now
but you you have to accept that you
don't want to blindly keep believing
that your parents are this person
because now your actions they don't they
aren't connected in reality they're not
and this is gonna sound kind of blunt
but you already were like unrealistic um
this disgust I'm really [ __ ] up your
parents are adults they're grown adults
this is not your problem
this is absolutely not your problem and
I also cannot express how much growth
people go through the minute they move
out of their home you your ego and
yourself is so tied to your parents
their mannerisms the way they raised you
that the minute you get out of the house
you start to separate and develop your
own sense of self you'll be surprised
how many tendons
mannerisms you've adopted from your
father and your mother that really
aren't yours they just kind of became a
part of you and there's some you'll
carry with you like do you have any
tendencies from your mom or dad that you
realize you still have we have so many
but at least now we recognize and we
were like I recognize all the [ __ ]
time
and it's so it's so interesting too
because I'd like might might might love
what I used to have this really bad
temper and it you know I've said this
before on Joe wouldn't Joe was here
we're just like a watered down version
of our parents every time and we only
come slightly upgraded from the [ __ ]
that they did yeah and that's really
that is like this whole [ __ ] you
mentality I'll do whatever I want it's
from my mom that's how my mom is all the
time oh [ __ ] gangsta yo my mom is so in
Korean she says how my name is how my
name is the pastor's wife right and
there is a certain why you're the
anointed one
I'm the anointed hallelujah but this is
a side-story why crack up about that I
had a buddy of mine where he was telling
story about one of when his grandma
passed away and this [ __ ] pastor like
as as [ __ ] like sitcom like black
family as ever this will told me during
his grandmother's funeral this fool was
playing like organs doesn't even really
know his grandma but he was like she was
a good woman she made the best sweet
potato pie she loved basketball and she
don't pass away was it too early but God
took a sit bone dude can we please get a
keyboardist for just one episode
constantly but we would be riding the
energy of the keyboardist it would be
like oh welcome back Double Down the
genius brain The Anointed One
I just want one beautiful 8000 black
woman and a beautiful ass hat and church
fat in ourselves going yes yes that dude
that David that's me take me like you
know I'm really you know the movies with
like the the like the old black lady or
in her probably early 40s and she really
just says yes baby
you go girl like that's literally me
bird that's literally me so I would be
that eighty year old woman with a big
hat leaving her imprints in the would
you ever seen that welcome back to
genius brain a podcast people is this a
religious podcast what's happening and
the first thing that happens is David's
Christian I lost my faith a long time I
really am I I feel like people get
surprised because like certain fans that
see me at this church that I go to and
they're like I go Church with a lot of
white people so I don't know who the
[ __ ] I am they're like good human being
so they don't watch the Jews my podcast
what the [ __ ] we talked about oh um you
wanted the side story oh yeah yeah you
your mama and your [ __ ] move out yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're all like a small
little reflection of our parents and I
can't I can't help but see those
specific type behaviors because my mom
was against she was a she I got that uh
[ __ ] you like I don't care mentality cuz
my mom was a homonym in the salmon team
is the pastor's wife and in Korean
culture at Korean church culture she can
do no wrong huh so she has to uphold a
certain type of I don't know I guess
like look or behavior that they expect
that I'm a pastor's wife right very
agreeable very warm yeah like you cream
like yeah yeah yeah I guess I'm down
which is like yes I understand and
they're you know very warm and kind well
they found the biggest Korean hillbilly
on earth to do that and my mom was not
that so they used to get in fights
because my dad's like you know my mom
curses a lot of Korean so if you wonder
why a crystal so much in English because
my mom curses
shit-ton in Korean so mine is just
translated to a different language so my
dad well I remember just listening to
this argument as a kid or my dad was
like you're us hominid you need to
behave like one right like you make me
look bad in the church when you behave
like this and my mom's I'll give up your
job give me what the [ __ ] am i sucked
into this [ __ ] you know but my mom you
know god bless her soul God be with her
she she was God
she uh she would cook for the church
every day almost every Sunday
make make food for like [ __ ] like 200
people she would work a six days a week
at the store like 80 hour weeks and then
when she would come back from like
working from like 7:00 a.m. to like 8:00
p.m. at night from 8:00 p.m. to like
2:00 in the morning she would be making
lunch for the Korean school in the
morning and then she would go to church
that next day and make food for the
church that's the type of woman that she
was so I understand her stress and why
she was so [ __ ] pissed like you know
I got to do all this [ __ ] and I got to
be your little [ __ ] little show pony
all the [ __ ] time like ya know if I'm
gonna be the pastor's wife I want to be
at home I want to be a stay at home
[ __ ] yeah that's what I want I want to
spend 80 hours a week on the couch just
pray while he teaches the gospel at the
church that's what I want I don't want
to be stressed Oh 100% I don't want that
stress is tough to do being a pat you
know like suicide rates in ministry
really high really it's really really
[ __ ] high I had a friend of mine who
is ism is a minister now and I didn't
know that he was going to this at the
time because you know just from looking
at somebody from the exterior they look
like they have everything together but
he tried killing himself and it was
because he couldn't take all the
pressure from being a spiritual leader
yeah also not very christ-like sir I
know can't do that that's what I'm
saying can't do that it's hard though
isn't it so crazy then within the
religion were you know killing yourself
as a sin that a lot of like youth
ministers go through that route where
they they have like a lot of suicidal
thoughts because of all this pressure
because like when you're a minister when
a lot of people don't know it's like you
can you go one way or the other you're
still gonna be seeing as you're [ __ ]
up something because you're supposed to
quote-unquote lead this flock or the
Sheep
so interesting because i honest to a
depression phase we're like you were
suicidal no I've never felt suicidal
every month
yeah I've been very sad like very deep
anything this depression right look I've
had a freshen before but I never thought
about killing myself because I was like
man you two dopes what's the world gonna
do with you I was it's so interesting to
be so far on the other side now but I
was I was what I would call passively
suicidal
we're like literally every day every
[ __ ] day I wanted to die but like I
didn't have the balls to like actually
do it that hurt I just yeah but like if
it happened to me I genuinely believed
that I would have been like happy and I
was I was so suit I was so suicidal that
I got I got so angry and I remember
being pissed off at somebody that
volunteered for a suicide prevention
thing because when I had to go through
that it their method of keeping you on
this earth is guilt tripping you it's
telling you that this person's gonna
miss you how could you do that to this
person and I was that made me so angry I
don't know if anyone else has ever been
had to go through some kind of suicide
prevention they they basically their
tactic is well let's just keep them here
for now and then we'll get them help but
for somebody that has the weight of the
world on their chest know what they mean
it's not it's not what they need at all
and it would piss me off so much because
I was like you are not me you are not
going through this you are not going
through this pain it is selfish for you
to want to keep me here when I don't
want to be here and I wanted so [ __ ]
bad I wanted so badly to kill myself I
really did like I just wanted to die but
I David when I was purchasing a car I
was looking up safest vehicles 29th are
you trying to you like precious cargo
yes absolutely a complete 180
I I built this life for myself that like
and in it and you know it started with
Smosh like I got I feel like I got so
lucky to get pulled into that and I
cannot imagine I can
I can't even go back to that place that
I was oh yeah we need a really dark
place that's why do it I can't come like
I'm like please say that's I had like
this episode where we're talking about
Sue and I brought a guest on who
attempted to kill herself and the reason
why is because I can't relate to it so I
can't really talk about it well yeah I
mean like I don't know what that feels
like
rami on oh [ __ ] I read you my diary
entries David you know I'm young I give
you all [ __ ] like dark stickers on it
stuff clothes thing I got to kill you
myself with bacon that's about it I'm
pretty [ __ ] good dude like I think
like the reason why I stayed alive was
just to piss people off it's like I'm
gonna kill myself I'm alive who you
gonna hate like I gotta stay alive just
to annoy you like why the [ __ ] do you
get to live and be happy [ __ ] she okay
so she was a cancer survivors my cancer
twice and then you even after she
survived cancer twice she had a really
good she her name is Kat sweets great
bakery self business person blows up
still didn't feel like it was worth
living because of all the [ __ ] that
she's going through she had a
miscarriage she lost her kid too as well
Wow
and then she decides to try to kill
herself and it luckily it didn't work
out yeah and you know I think like it's
it's hard because like when you're in
these like dark moments the the tool
that a lot of people don't have the
Primeau and I'm gathering from hearing
all these stories is that pain doesn't
feel temporary to some yes suicide that
is exactly what it is I I I don't really
give a lot of people advice on this
because I because my world took like a
full 180 after I joined Smosh and moved
out to LA shoutouts to Smosh and that
[ __ ] and that's not an opportunity that
a lot of people get so it's like my
situation isn't that relatable but what
ended up happening was I got plucked out
of this depression and just given a new
chance yeah and so then I started
looking okay
while I'm out here like how do I make
this work how do I do this so the only
thing lights help people is when you are
severely depressed when you're feeling
suicidal you need to find a mentor you
need I'm not even a mentor maybe like a
somebody to look up to what the [ __ ] is
that call a role model yeah you need a
role model that lives the life that you
want to live because you need to be able
to visualize yourself somewhere other
than where you are and whether it be
it sounds lack but creating a vision
board to just find that role model to
envision try to envision that life that
you want you you need that because
you're right it's like it feels like
this there's no way out of this pain and
the only way out of this pain is to end
everything and everything is temporary
and on top of that when you look at
these people who who you want to be like
and you see sometimes that it doesn't
feel like it's attainable a lot of
people don't share all the scars and the
wars that they went through just to get
to who they are as a person now and so
you're trying to you're trying to fast
forward these steps to see like I want
what they have without going everything
that they went through yeah they just
had like the mental fortitude to get
through it right so if you see this
where you like even for me if you look
at me as a hero Wow I fear for you guys
thank you very people say like well you
know like they're like oh how do you do
this like how did you start doing
stand-up to going into film and doing
all this other stuff it's like whoa
you weren't there for me when I got
booed off a stage you weren't there for
me when you know like little friends
have laughed saying that I couldn't
become a stand-up you were in there for
me when I've had like teachers tell me
that I wasn't gonna be anything like
these are stuff that built me up as a
human now it was very hard to get
through that [ __ ]
but at the same time it's like there's
no way that I would have been Who I am
now without that [ __ ] yeah because I
needed I needed to hear those type of
things it's just like for me at the time
and the tool that you don't have once
again is the fact that you thought you
think that when you go through that that
this is gonna be the rest of your life
and I never thought that it was like
this is temporary I have to get over
this [ __ ] I've talked about my anxiety
like how I used to there's probably the
third time I mention it but I want to
bring it up again because I've didn't I
couldn't order food at a fast-food
restaurant cuz I couldn't talk to people
because I had such anxiety
I was like oh god I gonna I got an order
I couldn't order for that restaurant a
fast-food restaurant
I couldn't make eye contact with people
I can do any of the [ __ ] that do we
stand it you know so come on like if if
somebody like me can do it I think that
you can too you just have to accept the
[ __ ] beating that you're gonna get to
get to victory that that ass-whooping
that you're gonna get is you just have
to accept it because it's going to
happen there are people out there right
now that are [ __ ] trash and even they
have a they're successful in their [ __ ]
and yeah in something they're resilient
or or you know those that ass beating
you have that that ass beating that
everyone's had that pain it's not just
in unfortunate instance it's not just
life [ __ ] on you it's a lesson every
single thing is a lesson and with each
instance of pain I don't think people
even realize how much stronger they're
getting yeah every day like I I I would
probably I would relive a lot of this
[ __ ] that's happened to me just like
just to become stronger like again like
I would I wouldn't if I could go back in
my life I wouldn't change anything there
is no situation that was so bad that I
was like oh I could do without that [ __ ]
no dude I learned something from that
and no matter how bad it was it made the
other bumps in the road less scary
because like like a-- and i use this as
an example for losing my job out of
nowhere like i career-wise I can conquer
anything I'm not afraid of anything like
in that field I'm really not unless like
somebody wants to like [ __ ] sue me
please don't sue me but I mean for the
most part like that that pain was a huge
lesson and it was like a huge elevator
because now the little things I'm not
scared of and it also lessened my
anxiety so much because when you conquer
it you're not constantly thinking about
it anymore because you know when it
comes up you got this whereas when I was
at my job when I first moved out here to
LA every single day I was like what's
gonna happen if I get fired
what if somebody hates me and I get
fired what the audience hates mean I get
fired
what if I [ __ ] something up and I get
fired what if I get fired what if I get
fired and then it was like okay now you
lost the job and then I conquered it and
then like it's not a fear of mining yeah
yeah I mean
it's just like this oh god I got really
not that say I wish like I try to commit
suicide but it's like one of those
things it's like damn this is something
that I really can't relate to yeah like
it's hard and I and I even relate this
back to something small so you know when
mr. so mr. Rogers passed away right I I
wasn't born here so I had to learn how
to speak English through every other
facet that wasn't my parents right it
was usually television and school and
whatever so um one of the shows that I
used to really really really really
[ __ ] love was mr. Rogers neighborhood
as a little kid when mr. Rogers died I
[ __ ] cried and I didn't know why
because I didn't really think much about
him right I was like mr. Rogers passed
away and I remember I was in my Isuzu
Trooper which was one of my first cars
ever and I was driving and it was like
from the Men's Wearhouse and I was
driving back to back home and I remember
this day because it hit me so hard when
he died I heard it on the radio and I
started bawling my [ __ ] eyes out
no and I remember I was sitting there
and I was thinking like what the [ __ ]
were you crying
I guess mr. Rogers like you know I mean
like do you even remember a single
episode that you saw from mr. Rogers at
all and I started to realize later on
when I was watching his show and I
watched this little clip of him trying
to gain financial support for public
television and it was his mantra and I
think that I like you it's crazy how
when you're a kid all these like
positive things that are fed to you
really do they it does affect you as an
adult you just don't know it yet they're
planting seeds yeah right and they're
just waiting for it to grow and so mr.
Rogers has this thing where he always
tell kids he always tells children or
when he was alive that you know how
important your existence is it was like
his main thing he would tell all the
time and I watched his show 24/7 as a
[ __ ] kid and that should blend into
my psyche as an adult I truly believe
that watching his show religiously as a
kid affected how I felt how I feel about
myself as an adult no matter what I went
through and mind you I went through some
[ __ ] terrible [ __ ] I never thought
that a way out would be for me to kill
myself Wow and I think it I really do
attribute to his show and a lot of like
public television or they kind of
instill this thought of you're important
you're worth it you're important
you're worth it and then it just starts
to build up inside me whether no matter
what I'm going through it always falls
back to that foundation and so what mr.
Rogers died I was like oh [ __ ] why did I
cry so much and I watched his show and I
watched that clip of him explaining why
Public Television his show is important
I'm like that's it that's the mantra I
live my whole life by and it's from this
little show that I used to watch to
another child I think that makes so much
sense and it's interesting because you
get all the wisdom from a man that's in
like his 60s and he has to translate it
into like he has this opportunity to
teach like what would I wish that I knew
when I was kid what do I want my
children to know and he's got a lot of
wisdom he's lived a lot of years and
it's so good that you got to learn
through that when I was a kid I grew up
watching Courage the Cowardly Dog and I
turned into that [ __ ] dog I was
mesmerized by the show I would watch it
every day and I as like a seven year old
I'm like this dog is absolutely right
something could go wrong at any point I
said you know Courage the Cowardly Dog I
became that little purple dog with
anxiety that's so [ __ ] funny
what about Winnie the Pooh you didn't
watch we know just courage you want to
watch you and invader zim [ __ ] is that
you don't know what invader zim is huh
like I think I literally watched every
fucked-up TV show and meanwhile you're
like in the neighborhood a beautiful day
in the neighborhood would you be mine I
so sweet so kind yeah yeah we need the
Pooh to also do Winnie the Pooh that's
the [ __ ] yeah we need the Pooh is so
part I think maybe the most positive
show I watched was bear in the Big Blue
House for this terrifying man in a bear
costume would just come out and be wacky
I don't even know what was going on in
the show and then I would watch Gullah
Gullah island because I had
representation dude that was how I was
raised Gullah Gullah island bear in the
big blue house invader zim encourage the
Cowardly Dog this is a horrible
okay I grew up like like winning the
pool is also some of those things where
I look at now if you watch the Winnie
the Pooh movie that came out maybe a few
years ago when it was they were like CG
animated and stuff I should make me bawl
my [ __ ] eyes out oh my gosh so
wholesome you know what that makes me
think I God I I don't think I'm gonna be
like one of those helicopter parents but
honestly this conversation right here
I'm gonna make sure that like a little
bit of what my kids watch is something
that's positive like that because they
don't really make [ __ ] like that anymore
it's all a cash grab now it's how do we
keep retention what are they watching
what is this but mr. Rogers it was just
a line and we absorbed the messages no
it it literally has to be and I get
scared because mmm I don't think people
realize like how much children absorb on
the daily yeah you know I think a lot of
it's just like oh let them do what they
want let them be free I agree with that
to a certain extent but I think I am
living proof of how those subliminal
little messages or even like straight up
messages as a kid does affect you as a
[ __ ] adult yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
how much Winnie the Pooh Calvin and
Hobbes like these little comic books I
used to read and stuff affected how I
spewed the world how I view myself even
till this day there are a lot of things
that I saw growing up past that but it
never stuck to me like these these
positive words of wisdom when I was a
little kid at the point where I didn't
even know it was affecting me like as an
adult I didn't get it I started balding
when I heard this old man who I haven't
seen since I was a little kid never even
thought about his show ones when he
passed away I started bawling my [ __ ]
eyes as if I lost a parent crazy well I
mean it's his legacy yeah I would just
would have never thought it would I
thought like if Barney passed away I've
been like man that what that was to do
does that ever inspire you at all just
try to create your own legacy um I don't
really care about legacy though
interesting legacy doesn't mean [ __ ] to
me legacy it but it legacy is not like
this is what I've done legacy is how
many people I've touched like in how
many people like when you said that I
was like I was like bows don't break
don't people have you touched how many
but I mean like people that you like
touch are affected like personally
because David you literally do a [ __ ]
podcast about advice or not advice for
legal reasons suggestions
and I mean you you are affecting
people's lives yeah I mean I think
that's probably if if you know I talked
about this on the patreon where I've
only stayed on YouTube now you two makes
me no money just distillate people know
I make money everywhere else but this
platform the only reason why I still
post YouTube now is because of people
who still enjoy the content because it
affects them in a positive way that's
really about it like I'm not sure if you
guys know this but Dave we talked a
david dobkin i'm saying his name oh yeah
david dobrik dobrik he put out his
article where he makes it the jillion
[ __ ] views and he makes like two
thousand dollars a month on adsense
alone that's how little youtubers make
money that's not all youtubers yeah but
if you don't have like kid-friendly
content this is what happens to you this
channel on on Adsense no makes about
like a thousand ish dollars a month
yeah the girls channel we'd never we
haven't even done a single check from
the YouTube pay I don't even know if
that channel has made any money I really
I really have no idea and then we make
money off of like doing sponsored stuff
but then also we really don't make [ __ ]
because we split it between six people
yeah that's why nobody will ever create
a group that's kind of like ours because
the networks have the split in mind and
our dumbasses put six girls together
it's gonna happen nobody went into it
for money and like you don't do this for
money we don't do our [ __ ] for money
it's for it's because I really really
enjoy it you know so I guess like if
we're gonna go to the topic of legacy
then yeah that's that's probably what it
is I'm glad I got to help people here
and there and mm-hmm once again things
that I say if it ever sounds harsh or
something like that I'm literally just
talking to myself it's because I don't
know you personally I don't know you
when I'm saying this advice I can only
speak to myself as if the advice that I
want to hear from somebody else that's
how I want to interpret things so I mean
back to your topic what are you talking
about your parents you got to realize
that your parents are human and it's
that's the hard part you have to yep you
have to process that you you absolutely
have to and if you don't process that
all of your actions are gonna be through
for example let's say you never this is
gonna sound [ __ ] up let's let's say
that you never cope with the fact that
your mother is a pork
you Nicator and she didn't know how to
communicate to her husband what she
needed so she went and found in somebody
else that [ __ ] sucks if you don't
accept that you will either a take on
that personality trait yourself because
it's been normalized or B you're gonna
believe no my mother's not that my
mother is this fantastic person I need
to help her no you don't need to help
her you then you're gonna try to stay
because you think you need to help this
little broken bird that has been hurt or
you know something like that or you
you're gonna think I need to be there
for your dad no you don't you're a 24
and you're a 21 year old man yeah you
absolutely do not have to and I can't
tell you enough how often David has to
tell me this sometimes I've been telling
people I've shot myself it's not your
problem
it is not worth your energy it's not
worth your thought it is not worth your
time and it's so difficult to set that
boundary when it comes to family it's so
difficult it's very very hard but if it
starts to suck you in but family is the
is the thing that will suck you in
harder than anyone else because you
believe that you believe blood I have to
I have to that's not true
yeah you can help where you can't help
but you still have to worry about
yourself too because when you kind of
cuz also too you only know your parents
is mom and dad you don't know your mom
is [ __ ] Daniel and gene whoever they
are to everybody else the side that you
see to your parents is only what you see
mom and dad shows you yeah
you don't know about your mom's personal
problems with like maybe like infidelity
tour trust issues or your dad's problem
with trust issues you don't know how
often that's happened that might really
[ __ ] you up that might be that might be
like when they were dating maybe your
mom cheated on your dad or maybe your
dad cheated on your mom before and there
was something that she held on before
maybe she's getting back at your dad
because he cheated in college you don't
know yeah maybe your dad is emotionally
unavailable for your mom all the time
and she constantly ignores her and then
her dad is a cuckold
yeah maybe your dad actually recorded it
he was masturbating to it constantly and
then she got tired of it cuz the [ __ ]
video leaked maybe your dad's not even
your dad
[Laughter]
like he goes back dad are you my real
dad takes off his mask is the [ __ ] is
me though it's hard when you see like
these flaws and your parents because
like I said it's I mean if you want to
wrap it back to yourself would you want
people to judge you without without an
ounce of forgiveness in their heart
you know without seeing you as a human
being that's allowed to make mistakes
that's allowed to get better from the
stuff sometimes parents even say I'm not
I'm not saying this is your case but I
know parents who have stayed together up
until the kid was 18 simply because they
didn't want to see their kids in a
broken household yeah sometimes worse
because a broken household doesn't have
to be a physical thing yeah it could be
what they see right in front of them
every [ __ ] day yep yeah that but I
think that I cannot say enough how it
it's not it's not your problem but wait
if you want to stick around for it it's
because you want to help and sometimes
the best thing that you can do to help
somebody is to let them fall flat on
their face you know if you if you're in
it also I think based off that message
he said that his mom wasn't taking
ownership of this yeah yeah she was kind
of going oh those another part where she
says she was victimizing herself by
telling other family members that she
was a biggie yeah so and like maybe if
it sounds like you know getting back to
like that whole conversation it sounds
like if anything just based off of the
information we have and sums up the dad
is really kind of a victim here and a
lot of times men they didn't your dad
does not need you his son to lean on
through all of this he wants to get
through this [ __ ] on his own he wants to
be on plenty of fish in six months after
he gets his own place doing his own [ __ ]
it's like what a man gets sick they
don't want you to take care of them like
you're your mom you never you never met
me then let me tell you something dude
when I get sick I cause a scene dude
David baby so yeah well I guess think
Mariel knows
like i and i'm like wrapped up and then
Muriel's like rolling her [ __ ] eyes
because it's like a cold or something a
common cold right I'm like everything
hurts
I guess who I learned that from my dad
my dad my dad would do that [ __ ] my dad
would be like oh I think I'm gonna die
you just hear my mom in the background
like shut the [ __ ] up dude it's a cold
yeah that's so funny well you're the
first guy I've met that's like that
because most men they're like no no I'm
good
they don't want to go to the dot you
know they say men they don't go to the
doctor for stuff oh yeah
men men are some of the last people to
go for mental mental help therapy or
what therapy I can't talk mental health
charity mental health [ __ ] they they
don't check in you know so like first of
all your mother needs to take some
accountability and I say this based off
of the information that we have yeah and
also she has a family support system of
people she's been complaining to that no
more than she does they're gonna have
more than you do because they're hiding
some stuff from you because you are
their child and they know more about the
backstory and they can help her you need
to get the [ __ ] out and you need to go
be your own man yeah and if you do want
to be involved be involved in the way
that you can but don't let it destroy
you because you don't know the whole
story and there's no way that you will
because they're not that open with you
I'm I actually were just remote a great
[ __ ] example I know somebody right
now that I know a lot of people well
that are going through a marital issues
and they're going to marital issues
right now and this is like problems that
they've had for quite a [ __ ] while
but it was buried in the fact that you
kind of focus on the kids and then you
don't really focus on the relationship
right what kids are getting older now
right and so when the kids are out of
the house and they start doing their own
thing you have to go circle back to your
personal issues that you had with each
other before and then you don't have
kids to distract you anymore yeah and so
you know they're going through their
problems they're fighting a lot more but
one of the one of the older kids got
involved right where he doesn't know the
type of stuff cuz i know cuz i've seen
it i've seen like their problems I've
been talking them through it for the
past few years now but the kid kind of
popped off on the mom was like you know
I always see you just
mouthing off at dad doing all this other
stuff blah blah blah and you're the
reason why everybody is unhappy in this
family - Ike mm-hmm
wow this locate doesn't know anything
you know because you know their parish
shielded them from that stuff the
personal issues yeah and that's why in
your case I give you some advice where
you probably don't know [ __ ] you
literally don't know [ __ ] just probably
weren't even supposed to find this out
yeah and that's probably an that kid you
know for him he just sees his mom being
upset at the dad but then at the same
time he also doesn't see the fact that
you know their personal issues of you
know him wanting to have sex with her
whenever he wants without any foreplay
yeah you know what being emotionally
unavailable may be exactly the fact that
he almost cheated on her a couple of
times see you don't know these the acted
but then you know he wants to pop off
and be I'm I know the problem and I'm
the solution like well you're also just
a [ __ ] kid still yeah and you you
don't know about the real problems and
so it's like for me on the outside on my
damn kids shut the [ __ ] up yeah and also
I never agree with sacrificing yourself
for somebody else's benefit because at
the end of the day the only thing that
you're getting out of it is that sense
of worth you're like I helped and that's
that is so fleeting it's I like to live
for myself and then live for others
after I'm more like I'm living for
myself and if you are tied into the mix
then so be it
um one of the things that I am
constantly constantly doing is um I make
a lot of connections like while I'm out
here and I'm very aware of what people's
skill set is and what their connection
is and if I start a project for example
I like it still in the works but just in
November I launched a production company
with a friend I had a friend that had a
particular skill set and she was not
doing so great wasn't super happy with
her job and so I'm like well I need you
but you also need this so I'll bring you
in but if I don't need your skill set
I'm not gonna just bring you in because
I want to be the Messiah that helps you
when you're in a bad situation
[ __ ] that and people do that [ __ ] all
the time
they want to write they want to feel
important by giving somebody either a
part of them or like in this case if I
were to just give her a portion of my
money because I wanted
feel like the Messiah but I'm like no
you have something that I want but I can
also wear intertwined
yeah it's mutually beneficial whenever
you're about to sacral I've to keep
someone else for him you need to really
look at it and be like what am I getting
out of this yeah it's okay to be selfish
you need you need to be somewhat selfish
to survive because you're living for
yourself at the end of the day you know
what you sound like - you sound like a
[ __ ] Nesbitt has God through some [ __ ]
[ __ ] everybody tell you something else
I've been through dis somebody dragged
you through the mud for sure dude that's
that's uh that's facts now you're like a
little more savvy about where you spend
your time with and who you really want
to give a [ __ ] about it's like cuz I
think people get [ __ ] up with that
[ __ ] - right they feel like they have to
think I owe if I'm doing well I have to
make sure this other person well well
because for me I was a people pleaser
for fifteen ten or fifteen years I I
don't know where it originated but
there's a phrase that I that I that I
absolutely hate that I hate so so much
and it's like it's when people say that
they they don't want to do something but
they're like but I don't want them to be
mad ooh I can't that was like a
cornerstone phrase for me all the time
like I either don't want to like take
this job or I don't want to go out and
do this or I don't want to do this
project but I don't want them to be mad
like I clearly don't want to do it but
I'm doing this for somebody else's
benefit and but it's so that they're not
mad at me so that they like me and Oh
living like that so tough I remember
exactly where I was walking when I was
on the phone with somebody complaining
about something after something just
didn't work out and I realized I have
been sacrificing myself and doing things
for other people this was maybe two
years ago I was like for 10 years and at
this point I have nothing to show for it
I have been bending over backwards doing
anything and everything for whenever
somebody needed something I was there
emotion
we financially physically anything I was
there but it's because I based my
self-worth on did they like me or not
and then after 10 years I realized I had
nothing to show for it
literally nothing I had I did not have
stronger connections those people liked
me because they liked my personality not
because of the things I had done for
them not because I was always available
they just liked my personality so I
could have not wasted that time or those
energy of those resources and I would
have had the same [ __ ] relationship
with them like get it being a people
pleaser is your own trap yeah it's a
hundred percent your own trap did you
ever have people pleasing tendencies oh
I was really really really young but
that [ __ ] got really exhausting after a
while if anything else I got in too much
trouble because I didn't people please a
little bit like I was just always like
this is who I am yeah and always trying
to figure it out it was so hard I think
it was just like I mean everybody went
to that phase where you're trying to
just say things to always keep the peace
like I mentioned like in high school
like you have ten people you like two
people you get to give a [ __ ] about but
you tolerate them because you just want
to please everybody else around you but
at a certain point that got exhausting
for me like I just didn't care I didn't
have it as much as other people did but
I do understand what that feels like
yeah like giving so much of yourself
that you forget that your opinions
matter how you feel matters and at the
end of the day it's just it's you and
your in your choices that's why I even
use that advice where people who develop
relationships with other people to
please their parents I'm gonna get with
this person because I know that this
person is somebody my parents would like
well what about you you like that person
yeah you're pears are gonna die one day
yeah you're gonna be left with them
you're gonna be left with the children
that you have with them the house that
you buy with them the cars that you get
and the money that you share where's
your parents then yeah imagine being
like well I picked them because I can
bring her home to my mother you're gonna
be happy when you have to go home with
her
yeah like family is an important thing
and my mom understands that to him but
even my mom told me she goes you know
what like I would love to have a
daughter-in-law that I could speak to
and everything else she was by at the
end of the day I'm gonna pass away and
then you have to live with that choice
with who you end up with and so even my
mom gets it she wants certain things
like she would love for that girl to
speak Korean she would love to develop a
relationship with that but she knows
that she's gonna go away one day
I'm gonna be left with the wife that I
don't like damn I can't believe your mom
said my mom's why isn't dumb as [ __ ] at
the same time dude everything that you
do it should be mutually beneficial
I mean if it's in collaboration with
somebody else or you're worried about
somebody else's opinion friendship for
like that to them they a good friendship
is yeah and you notice that when it's a
toxic friendship it's not mutually
beneficial it should be with this I've
seen a lot of friendships fall apart
because it wasn't a symbiotic
relationship because it's they thought
it was a ship but it wasn't it was one
friend taking taking taking yeah other
person didn't have anything to offer
except for maybe like some laughs and
some good time right but that person was
not a stable human being and then they
were all they've the friendship was
based on them giving them advice
building them up building them up
building them up but when they had a
problem they had nothing to offer they
couldn't offer them advice right and
give them financial help couldn't do
anything for them and then when things
fall apart they're like oh [ __ ] it's
like oh well I guess like I didn't we're
not on the same level like I'm over here
and you're right here and the other
person feels like whoa you think you're
better than me it's like no it's not
that they think they're better than you
or that there were certain issues that
you guys had it's just that you took in
the friendship all the time and you had
nothing to give back right
so that person get got tired of it it's
like you've been friends of the
narcissist before yes I feel like almost
everyone has it is the most draining
thing me me me me me me me me me I'm
like they'll call you and they just want
to talk about that this thing that
happened to them and then okay I told
you my story alright bye yep I mean it's
the most absolutely draining thing like
you just took the 30 to 45 minutes of my
time telling me this story that you
think is hilarious and then no bye yeah
like what what I didn't get to talk do
you care about my day what's going on
there and then the person on the with
the shorted in this day they start to
feel it
they may not be able to pinpoint like
okay this isn't a mutually beneficial
thing but they kind of either stiff like
my way or they act out or they something
and those friendships do not work out
they do not it like you know what they
taught us in school how to do a [ __ ]
Venn diagram okay if something doesn't
feel right you pull out your mental Venn
diagram and you're like okay wait am i
getting in here what did this person get
over here what are we both getting that
there's no congruent
does this look congruent and like you
can run through that in your head in
five minutes
look you should do that and if it's not
congruent snip-snip goodbye we've had
our time here goodbye and I say that the
same thing with family too same exact
thing with family like okay for our guy
what was his name Logan Logan Logan
Logan Logan Stoll Logan you're 21 at
this point now look at this relationship
with your mother
is it mutually beneficial okay now you
have your own funds you can live in your
own house your mother is no longer
feeding you clothing you and putting
this roof over your head well what is
she supplying to you now like it sounds
like you're like yes this is my mother
this is my blood but you're the reason
our mothers are motherly is because they
are helping they are a gentle force
they're there to catch us when we fall
and that is providing some kind of
support for you are you getting that
support yeah I mean for me like I like
family super important to me but tonight
you know I have a [ __ ] family but
they've they've always like we've always
had a good tie yeah each other you know
because my parents are nowhere near
perfect at all if I could tell you the
battles and the personal stories that we
went through to to get how we are now it
was it was hard yeah it was super
[ __ ] hard I shared the story a while
back where my dad uh and I just we never
saw eye-to-eye like ever we fought all
the [ __ ] time I think my dad looking
at me pissed him off like just my very
presence made my father angry man and it
was it was it was a hard time for me
because I wasn't the son that he wanted
me to be I wasn't I would I didn't go to
a really great college I didn't get
straight A's and he thought that he did
everything in his power to set it up
right he goes I did this I did this for
you I did that I did that how come you
didn't turn out to be like this but he
never really asked David what is it that
you want
my parent never asked me that either
yeah and they and their and they were so
bitter about everything that they had
set up for me and and then that wasn't
for me that was for you because you
don't know what I want and what I want
is what is best for me cuz that's what's
gonna make me feel the most fulfilled
because I don't I don't get it like we
your children do not want to be
destitute
I want it when I'm 30 I want to eat and
I want to pay my bills so what I want in
life even if I'm a child and I'm
figuring [ __ ] out is gonna be something
that is sustainable like I'm gonna
survive so you don't need to set me up
to be a doctor yeah I'm not gonna be
fulfilled and I would rather sounds so
dumb like well cuz I need look [ __ ]
needs money but I want to be fulfilled
you want to be fulfilled in life my
number one top priority is not money its
fulfillment and even there sometimes
when parents tell you that you you
communicate what you want and they think
that they're going along with what
you're saying they still have to encase
it in the way that they want to do it
right it's like so like my dad I don't
know how many times this full said this
to me he goes I told my wanted to be a
stand-up comic and this is what I was
going to I was gonna go into comedy he
was cool I'm gonna sign you up for
comedy College I was like hey what the
[ __ ] is common what the [ __ ] is comedy
College doing is like it's a comedy
College dude we're gonna send you and
this will sends me a link right cuz he
hates being wrong he goes boom I told
you there's comedy College he sent me
this [ __ ] from an Ivy League school in a
Fiat in a theater program I was like you
do realize I have to get into the Ivy
League school and it's not comedy
College it's a theater major you
[ __ ] I mean he doesn't understand
these type of things there's nothing in
this world that's gonna teach you how to
do stand-up there's there's classes
where they learn how to do stand-up
comedy nobody turns out to be a great
stand-up comic from that [ __ ] I don't
believe it anyways I think like you can
learn how to set up jokes right you can
learn how to write jokes
yeah setting up jokes is a format yeah
and maybe you can practice your delivery
but there is no 1 2 3 it's not like
history class exactly so he was like
trying to make up these things that
didn't [ __ ] exist and I was like I
could take an improv class and stuff
like that maybe that'll help out but
it's not a college it's not a four-year
[ __ ] course where I get you
it's accredits like you know I ask are
they how do they feel about everything
you're doing now everything oh [ __ ]
Asian people's like they see money okay
good time you know so it's like do they
walk like I mean they they don't have to
watch everything but do they are they
proud of what you're doing do you I'm
not sure the word proud is but I think
they're more not so much of what I'm
doing they're proud that I could support
myself and I could support people who
need help that you figured it out yeah
so they don't they don't care about I
think they just always wanted to know
that I would be okay that I could
survive yeah and then it was just really
hard just not having them believe that I
could do what I want doing it my dad and
I had this huge fight this is years ago
in the last huge fight that we had
and I literally told him I was like
could you imagine how great I would have
been faster if you would have just
showed me support yeah but you chose not
to I was like you made that choice when
I asked you for help
you called me dumb you called me stupid
and for a whole year I didn't talk to
you for a whole year I left the house we
didn't have any communication because
all you could see that what I was doing
was done because it wasn't what you
thought you wanted me to do right how
different what our relationship be if
you would have just listened yeah you
know I think that kind of hurt him or
you know yeah
we're just asked or cared yeah I mean
they they just you know sometimes
parents they think they're 100 percent
right my mom lived this like earlier and
the thing it's a phrase it's ingrained
in me my mom would say I'm the parent
you were the child and it would make me
feel so small yeah and you know I can't
express enough like ask your kids kids
how they're doing like ask like and
really care really care you don't you
don't know everything about your kid you
may know where they're at you may know
what classes they're enrolled in you
know their teacher's name but you don't
know what their thoughts are even you
never know unless you ask and it's just
so incredibly important to teach
children that their thoughts are valued
you know I I'm really lucky that like my
my mom did not practice that growing up
but Jesus Christ that woman is my
biggest [ __ ] fan she's watched she
watching this [ __ ] right now like I
already know it she's my biggest fan
even before I moved out to LA when I was
on Twitch my mom she's still subscribed
to my twitch channel
she was in my channel 24/7 just watching
and she would say lay what time are you
going on and I'm like it's not a it's
not a theater show I just streaming yeah
video games and she's like she's so
she's so happy in it and I think it
makes things easier for me to I you know
what you mentioned david dobrik earlier
and like this this is kind of in the
same realm but it just kind of late
leads me into like gratefulness because
sometimes I have to remind myself like
him I'm really I'm doing this [ __ ] you
know I'm we're paving a way for
ourselves no one expected and I feel
like sometimes I take it for granted and
I heard somewhere that david dobrik had
said one time that uh sometimes when he
feels like he's not grateful for it he
tries to see his day to day through the
lens of his 18 year old self and i did
that one time and I thought about it and
I was like okay 18 year old bows you
know living out here in LA doing all
this [ __ ] cuz I never would have liked
fathom that I was like my first thought
I was like damn [ __ ] don't touch
anything don't [ __ ] it up I eighteen
year old me would not know how to run
the life that I'm living now oh yeah
would have no idea like how do you see
yourself as eighteen year old David
right here I was with my very first
girlfriend and I was very very happy
with her because that's the first time I
[ __ ] and it was great and then I was
also miserable because I was forced to
go to UC Riverside I didn't want to go
there and my dad and I had a very
terrible relationship don't draw
yourself out of that and put yourself in
the seat right there isn't it [ __ ]
weird
yeah but memorize our said to I could
never go back in time I never want to go
through that [ __ ] again Terry happy to
be here like we did a whole I did a
whole podcast on about gratitude and
like how important it is yeah and it's
it's it's very easy to see your cup half
empty all the time very easy yeah it's
just you have to really make that
conscious choice it's it's just so corny
to say this but man [ __ ] two eyes
hands and feet I can walk I could do
everything yeah give me something as
simple as that people don't have that
privilege people think is a privilege
you know what I think is I it sounds
really whack too okay there's some like
there's there's not the whole like Law
of Attraction
we're like you try to like manifest your
goals you know you write things down and
you go for it and then there's also
gratitude and they're kind of considered
new agey things that it's like oh that's
cheesy writing down manifesting your
goals and and doing practicing gratitude
you show me today but actually it's so
common that it was adopted in
Christianity because thanking God for
everything you have is practicing
gratitude praying for things that you
want to God is practicing like
manifesting your destiny it's the same
[ __ ] you picked up in different
religions it's not that weird to do and
in Christianity when you are praying or
not even Christianity all religions when
you're praying and you're asking for
things are being thankful for things you
are practicing gratitude and the law of
attraction every single day that's why
like I still [ __ ] with Christianity man
like there's a lot of stuff that I think
the religion is great just sometimes you
know the people [ __ ] it up yeah but like
a lot of the stuff that I think people
that are trying to learn from this
podcast exactly stuff they learned in
church like the gratefulness yeah you
know learning how to be kind to it I'm
telling you if I didn't have church I
think I'd be a serial killer yeah I
think I would just literally just murder
people just because I feel like they
deserve it yeah for sure
you know and so now I'm just like oh I
can see like vibe me growing up in a
church really taught me to be to help
people when they need help to extend
love you know to create community all
this other stuff
even though like I don't attend churches
as much as I used to but all that stuff
was embedded to me because of the church
community that I had I agree yeah even
though I'm not religious now that good
intention is still kind of like embedded
in me like I can't shake it so I'm a
good person man [ __ ] this is so hard
just want to kick somebody you know
Jesus my Christian heart dude my
Christian guilt kicks in all the time
like when you were like suck mine I was
like see I grew up in a Christian house
oh but I also grew up in a very ghetto
area so that stuff all blends together
it's like praise the Lord but [ __ ] you
my mom never even cursed oh dude I'm
heard my mom cursed one time and she was
like well you know
the hey Shh where to god I'd the only
time I've heard curse is when she said
the name of show and normally shows and
say it you know it reminds me of like
your mom is like George I would be like
no not your mom but I would be like have
you seen there's a key and Pierce sketch
with a called Jordan Esther yes Church
oh my god that's my grandma my grandma
is an usher at a church really yes yes
she's been she's been an usher I a shirt
for like 40 years
damn yeah she in there with the hat
everything standing up now I am a
pacifist but if my shoulder is about to
cry Maximus anyways guys I think this
wraps this episode of the jeans by a
podcast
anyways guys ending this wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
please follow my guest David where can
they find you they can find me on my
podcast so company
well Bose where can they find you so
much for watching the Boat Show you can
follow me on instagram at big boss pose
make sure you like subscribe and drop us
a comment below we want to do the advice
call them again
send us some good stuff and you know
what even if it's something you're not
working through right now if it's
something you've worked through in the
past and you're like I wonder how I
could have done this differently send
that [ __ ] in you never know what people
are in the same exact situation thanks
for watching we'll see you next time
that was way better than any anger I've
ever done on this show
[ __ ] yes she is she's out doing me I
mean what the [ __ ] is that
hey guys
would you guys have a problem you come
through in the [ __ ] other time
something
see you next time